but first my thoughts at the end of day
35 America in shutdown Democrats taking
the viral path to socialism you feel it
don't you and you you see it you sense
it there's a growing divide in America
in this kovat nineteen era and I'm not
talking about rich versus poor or black
versus white or even red state versus
blue state I'm talking about the growing
tension between the open now coalition
versus the stay closed and perpetuity
contingent now the angle told you weeks
ago that if people began to see the
government's response to the coronavirus
as more toxic than the virus itself well
things would start to get heated that's
what we've been seeing over the past
week or so
[Music]
it's about your constitutional rights
we're being muzzled by the government
and don't let the mask that you wear
turn into that muzzle and the president
even chimed in yesterday people feel
that way you're allowed to protest I
mean think they feel that way I watched
the protest and they were all six feet
apart that beta was a very orderly group
of people and up but you know some some
have gone too far some governors have
gone too far
now the folks protesting the stay at
home orders are mostly small business
owners their moms or dads students even
who are seeing their futures go down the
drain of course they're worried about
their fellow man of course they want to
keep the vulnerable the elderly safe and
secure but they also complain about
needless and arbitrary rules that
declare bike stores essential but not
churches now this video was probably one
of the more disturbing visuals from the
last weekend officials in San Clemente
poured 37 tons of sand into Ralph's
skate court after skateboarders were
caught routinely ignoring the no
trespassing signs now come on this is
kind of pathetic don't you think our
teens getting sunshine
zoomin past each other really the
problem here the big threat to
civilization I guess maybe I don't know
but over the weekend we learned that
government researchers have found that
simulated sunlight rapidly killed the
virus and aerosols hmm sunlight could
actually kill it like mom always said
fresh air and sunshine really is the
best disinfectant but even if you who do
socially distance in California remember
you're socially distance but you can
still be snitched upon if you've
observed recurring violations of the
safer at home order please continue to
let us know at coronavirus LA City org
slash business violation you know the
old expression about snitches well in
this case snitches get rewards snitches
get rewards that one comment told you
everything you need to know about how
far elected officials are actually
willing to go to enforce a new normal a
phrase I despise because a new normal
means civil liberties be damned
but even when snitches aren't snitching
watch yourselves because drones are
flying overhead the drones make it
easier for police to see into certain
areas where access by patrol cars is
more difficult that includes tight
spaces between buildings behind schools
and in backyards the drones donated by
DJI a Chinese company have gone to 43
agencies in 22 states Chinese affiliated
drone company I into that I'm not saying
oh brother I say Oh Big Brother now
beyond the noble motives of keeping
Americans safe and free at the same time
is the ignoble goal of using this crisis
to remake American society according to
more progressive ideals let's use this
situation this crisis this time
to actually learn the lessons value from
the reflection and let's reimagine what
we want society to be how do we have a
better transportation system a better
housing system better public safety
system better health system better
better social equity and let's use this
as a moment to really plan change that
we could normally never do unless you
had this situation oh that's it change
you could never do if he actually had to
run it by the state legislature perhaps
or maybe he's just talking about
improving the state government's
response to future heaven forbid
pandemics that would be fine well that
would also require taking a hard look at
why your state budget errs nixed
ventilators in favor of social welfare
projects meanwhile you get the sense
that someone out there is feeling a
little left out in this Kovach crisis
because she's dreaming up a storm on
Instagram incremental ISM is not helpful
in this moment we have to make sure that
we demand meaningful change in
meaningful assistance for working
families
that means 2,000 a month plus a thousand
for your kids
recurring that's a that's a pretty good
amount 2,000 a month why stop it ii
thought 5,000 a week do I hear six
alright on the left coast though they're
not about to be outdone by the New
Yorkers because Governor Gavin Newsom
has his own ideas about how to use the
shutdown to open up a path of new
climate change policies his new task
force will be headed by none other than
drumroll please that every man Tom
Steyer the billionaire who believes in
banning fossil fuels a wealth tax and
slavery reparations he says the goal of
the task force is to recover as fast and
as safely as possible from the Cova 19
induced recession and to create a fair
green and prosperous future that
remedies some of the in justices which
this kovin 19 pandemic has revealed in
our society
this pandemic has revealed a lot all
right about China about state
preparedness about the ineptitude of the
CDC and about Democrats unwillingness to
tolerate dissent because if you're
someone who believes the shut downs in
most states now are hurting in many
cases more than helping well you're
gonna be labeled a pariah and
anti-science and heaven forbid if you
choose to exercise your First Amendment
rights to peaceably protest it's
somebody trying to organize something
like that it's wrong for information we
do classify that as harmfulness
information and we take that downs I
think a lot of the stuff that people are
saying that is false around a health
emergency like this can be classified as
is conchal misinformation harmful
misinformation now what's more true here
New York will need 32,000 ventilators
that's sparked a lot of panic right was
that harmful or this I think it was the
worst probably the worst week of my life
pretty much looking at possibly losing
everything we worked for the first week
we've got lost already 80% of our
inventory right now we're zero
everywhere I mean no one's it's it's I
would have it's even worse than I would
have guessed so if those folks wanted to
show up and peacefully protest that
would be part of the harmful
disinformation campaign as we take him
down from Facebook I need the new rules
so snitching spying with drones limiting
speech chasing surfers off beaches or
skateboarders out of skate parks where
there are few proportionately very few
Kovac cases none of that sounds very
healing to me and those are my thoughts
at the end of day 35 America in shutdown